[Musique]
à
c'était le sort je crois il était 20h et
de la jeter au piano a lâchement j'étais
en train de jouer à duke est venu comme
ça qui venu et il a surgi sans tel match
peu de films et archives azim hajee ce
témoin est une
enfin comme on appelle ça la reprendre
c'est faux ni un bail comme ça et moi je
moi je
dj les symphonies ça se prononce sur un
orque a fait tout ça et du coup je les
fais le truc que j'avais fait le plus
vite je les fais il a filmé ce parti
je rentre chez moi il y avait ma mère
mon père a réellement le cas
kappa réalisée j'ai réalisé après et
apprécier passé tellement vite
[Musique]
une fois je suis arrivé et c'était le
lendemain d'une grande fusillade et donc
il était hors de question qu'on
travaille avec les enfants il y avait
juste besoin de panser les blessures et
du coup j'ai sorti mon accordéon je me
suis mise à chanter devra d'ici mise à
improviser
j'ai été transpercée par la musicalité
de ce petit garçon de 9 ans qui avait
jamais fait de musique qui avait jamais
chanté qui se met à chanter et c'était
magique quoi on a fait un opéra c'était
un projet du coup il y avait de la
musique classique contemporaine et du
coup je me suis dit et qu'il va aller
voir c'est quoi chalier serait internet
je regardais de trois vidéos
je m'intéresse pas du tout aux canons
mais je savais y avait un panneau à côté
d'eux
la salle du coup à chaque forme jallier
jouer vite et comme ça normal comme un
enfant et après je me suis dit il faut
regarder des vidéos commentées du piano
touches concorde et une à deux vidéos
j'ai pris trois accords après je me suis
dit j'y allais je le fais comme ça j'ai
écouté que j'écoutais j'écoutais j'ai
plus du tout joué j'écoutais un jour
charles à la timone et j'ai joué j'ai
fait pour ça il va me mettre en colère
j'ai demandé voilà quels instruments ils
avaient envie de jouer et l'a dit le
canot du coup bah j'ai organisé une
collecte de fonds pour lui payer des
cours de piano et voilà il a commencé à
prendre ses premiers cours il n'y avait
pas de piano chez lui et très vite ses
parents
ils ont acheté au noël donc c'était un
mois après deux mois après l'on payé un
petit piano k est vite rendu l'âme
malheureusement et après voilà ils
allaient jouer sur les haies puis à nous
en libre service
[Musique]
ma pièce dictionnaire ce que je réside à
l'issue de ce quartier et qu'il a réussi
un peu pareil comme comme gt s
entraînant foot à chaque fois et ça même
si tu viens d'être énorme et je viens de
partout que je peux faire du piano d'un
quartier défavorisé même site et hyper
port dû prendre notre marque en tout
c'est juste que nous on a pas on n'a pas
tous toutes ces ouvertures
il ya des assassinats des tricks en
place dans les quartiers nord mais on
n'a pas assez pour faire découvrir aux
jeunes qui a des métiers qui a pas que
la pauvreté qui as du piano classique il
y en a pas assez c'est pour ça qu'on n'a
pas
c'est pas trop énergie c'est pour ça que
les gens il
france un gros jeu
on défend l'idée même de coller des
merdes qu'on vient des quartiers nord on
ici on est là mais n'a en fait tu chaque
chaque personne un talent peut-être on
sait pas où ça peut se réveiller je suis
pas il y en a dans la musique je veux
dire de partout dans masson danse du
tout
[Musique]
à
le drame c'est bien ce que m'a dit j'ai
jamais faite
car si impressionnant
j'ai trouvé plus impressionnant en fait
c'est gore
personne dans le stade il y avait
le stade est que quand tu rates tu vois
toutes ses places et où ils marseille
grand est tous en même temps il ya plein
de stars qui sont pas assez connues mais
tout et c'est impressionnant jusqu'en
juste que tu te rendes quand après avec
les gens j'étais habitué le mater chez
venu je suis en répète et tout l'après
midi
vale à prier
j'allais si je le fais
quand je rentre sur scène en fait
georges froid d'autant qu'elle fait elle
de 300 offres
après y'a je t'en foutais des athlètes
chouchou
[Musique]
à
c'est quoi ton dos mon rêve mon rêve
party 2
avec qualitative et
c'est toujours
quoi les acquis
ad oui pourquoi il s'accuse parce que
déjà elle est bel et bien et c'est tout
[Musique]